this is a special episode fighter in the
kid Brian kid counting his [ __ ] TV
show travels absolute trash right no
it's bad which one is it which one of
these which one should which shitty
spin-off is he doing now who knows he
plays in a coach with Ricky I don't know
dude but gym teacher this guy's that was
the ward they'll worse I'm glad I'm here
so I decided to fill his chair with
Bryan Callen and then of course we we
filled Brian Collins chair with the red
rock that's right all right the red
rocket tourists coming in 2020 come on
bro what's up baby it shows what's up
baby don't trying to do it and then we
got to me when the greatest comedians
alive right now
hey Andrew Schultz we play oh thank you
very all the way from New York man yeah
you know I didn't know that that uh
Santino and Kalin had like a friendly
beef mm-hmm it's hilarious it's not
friendly anymore apparently not you know
it we were on stage at our show the
other day at the store in the main room
hey Santino Santino is a passionate
fiery guy the most fun someone who just
goes so how do you really feel about
kaolin he says that the Santino and it's
a to you sort of ripping like what bro
he's like going is like his materials
days look like I let me take the
microphone wax days for two people here
was lighting him up I feel like you're
that way with everybody except me really
except for you yeah but I but I do that
with Callum because I just his little
cocky attitude he's got to way too much
attitude when he comes in the green room
he's got way too much attitude he
prances around like he owns the place I
don't like it even as money a lot like
the Lea flashes money yeah but it's
different because it's fun yeah Callan
does it and it makes me so [ __ ] mad
dude I want to choke him out and kill
him as a little skinny neck I'm back to
thinking this is real yeah I think I was
right it's like the things he was saying
weren't like it's personal again it was
really it was like his hair Stan you
like why would you even mention
that's right divorce
[Laughter]
Costa County yeah yeah yeah yeah watch
your tongue oh good what's gonna happen
what are you gonna do use some of that
boxing you've been doing
[Laughter]